I would like to welcome you to biology
at Khan Academy and biology as you might
know is the study of life and I can't
really imagine anything more interesting
than the study of life and when I say
life I'm not just talking about us human
beings I'm talking about all animals I'm
talking about plants I'm talking about
bacteria and it really is fascinating
how do we start off with in adamant
molecules and atoms this right here is a
molecule of DNA how do we start with
things like that and we get the
complexity of living things and you
might be saying well well what makes
something living well living things
convert energy from one form to another
they use that energy to grow they use
that energy to change and I guess growth
is a form of change they use that energy
to reproduce and these are all in and of
themselves fascinating questions how do
they do this you know we look around us
how do we you know eat a muffin and how
does that allow us to move around and
think and do all the things we do where
did the energy from that muffin come
from how are we similar to a plant or an
insect and we are we are eerily or
strangely similar to these things we
actually can't have a lot more in common
with you know that tree outside your
window or that that insect that'd be
that might be buzzing around then you
realize even with the bacteria that said
that you can only even that you cannot
even only even see at a microscopic
level in fact we have so much bacteria
as part of what makes us us so these are
fascinating questions how do we how does
how did life even emerge and so over the
course of what you see in biology on
Khan Academy we're going to answer these
fundamental fascinating questions we're
going to think about things like energy
and the role of energy in life we're
going to think about important molecules
in biology and perhaps most importantly
DNA and its role in reproduction and
containing information and we're going
to study cells
which are the basic building block of
life and as we'll see even though we
view cells as these super super small
small things cells in and of themselves
are incredibly complex and if you
compare them to an atomic scale they're
quite large in fact this entire this
blue background that I have there that's
the surface of an immune cell and what
you see here emerging from it these
these little yellow things these are HIV
viruses merging from immunes
from an immune cell so even though you
imagine cells is these very very small
microscopic things there's incredible
complexity even viruses viruses are one
of these fascinating things that kind of
are right on the edge between life and
non-life
they definitely reproduce and they
definitely evolve but they don't
necessarily have a metabolism and we'll
learn a lot more about that they don't
let us necessarily use energy and growth
in the same way that we would associate
with life and then perhaps one of the
biggest questions of all is how did life
come about and we will study that as we
look at evolution and natural selection
so welcome to Khan Academy's biology
section I think you're going to find it
fascinating you're going to realize that
biology in some way is is the most
complex of the science isn't in a lot of
ways the one that we understand the
least it's going to be built on top of
chemistry which in turn is built on top
of physics which in turn is built on top
of mathematics and biology is one rankly
even in the last hundred years we're
just starting to scratch the surface of
understanding it but what's really
exciting is where the field of biology
is going as we understand things at a
deeper level at a molecular level we're
going to start thinking about how can we
even do things like engineer biology or
affect the world around us it's going to
raise all sorts of fascinating in deep
and ethical questions so hopefully you
enjoy this biology is one of the most
arguably maybe the most fascinating
subject of all I don't want to offend
the chemists in the physics out there I
actually find those quite fascinating as
well we're going to answer or attempt to
start to answer
some of the most fundamental questions
of our existence